[Music]
question how do you stage a battle scene
that features three aggressors who have
never been pitted against each other on
film before well if you're the team at
Game of Thrones you're in luck because
although there is no one battle that's
configured quite like the loot train
attack from this Sunday that's a
ridiculous name film and TV history is
full of creative ways to tackle each one
individually all you have to figure out
is how to fuse them together into one
giant Frankenstein monster battle now
that's a [__] name in fact all
cinematic battles work this way like a
great oral tradition that continually
builds on and reconfigures what came
before the DNA of one battle lives on in
the battles that follow and you can see
that DNA everywhere and the loot train
attack so much so that I think you could
essentially reconstruct this sequence
with other movies what courage I love
that this battle starts with the thunder
of Dothraki horses arriving before they
do you can find that same effect in both
300 and Troy in Lord of the Rings Return
of the King you have a similar situation
where the orcs like the Lannisters have
to reform ranks at a moment's notice to
face an enemy that's just about to
appear over the ridge the Dothraki are
based on a combination of horse riding
tribes like the Mongols or the Huns so
you can look at movies like the 2007
Russian film Mongol defined battle cries
and weapons just like these but the
Dothraki are also based on Native
Americans so it makes sense that Matt
Shak Minh the director of this episode
would cite the classic John Ford film
stagecoach as an inspiration for this
scene and clearly the landscape is
nodding to Monument Valley Utah and
Arizona where Ford set many of his
famous westerns and you do have a few
shots that are completely unique
now when it comes to fire-breathing
dragons you have plenty to choose from
in film history you've got the hungarian
horntail from harry potter you've got
verma Thrax pejorative from dragon
slayer who roasts some people of his own
you've got the dragon from Eragon and of
course you have Smaug
all of these no doubt influenced the
depictions have drogon in the scene I
think there's a few other sources that
has an even greater influence here in
terms of the devastation that drogue on
visits on the battlefield the clearest
analog I can see is the helicopter and
napalm attacks from Apocalypse Now in
fact in The Hollywood Reporter Shakman
cites this as another inspiration and
some of the shots are uncannily similar
I mean this is just a beautiful mix of
practical and digital effects and it's
not only the napalm the point of view
shots of Daenerys on Dragon's Back are a
lot like the POV shots from the
helicopters and this scene from
Apocalypse on the ground you'll find
some similarities to the first scene in
gladiator where the Romans rain down
fire balls and fire arrows on the
Germanic tribes Ridley Scott does a
great job of depicting the chaos of a
battlefield on fire
of course Jackman and crew can't resist
adding their own flair here as well with
a few soldiers but really roasting in
their Armour Game of Thrones isn't just
sighting from other properties sites
from itself - though this wonderful
handheld longshot featuring Bronn making
its way across the battlefield resembles
the new bestie camerawork in the
revenant and even children of men I
think the real touchstone is this long
shot from the Battle of the bastard
graphism
director Miguel Zapata crafted one of
the best sequences in the history of war
cinematography and it's certainly worth
drawing from the last thing that Jackman
cites explicitly is Saving Private Ryan
no doubt an inspiration for any war
filmmaker these days here Thrones mimics
that effect when the real sound fades
out and we focus in on the shock of the
commander as he surveys the field
carnage finally the ending of the scene
plays out like the end of the fight
against Smaug in The Hobbit battle of
the five armies when the dragon goes up
against a man with a giant arrow and
gets angry as you can see in filmmaking
like this there's barely anything that
new but the team at Game of Thrones from
the director on down did a wonderful job
of combining multiple sources to make a
battle that's tense intelligible and
more than the sum of its parts
for those who ever want to compose a
cinematic battle of their own this is
how you do it worst of the metagraph E
is like lang
most of the words have been used before
that doesn't mean that something new
can't be rich
everybody thank you so much for watching
I'm so excited that Game of Thrones is
finally back and I forgot how much I
appreciated watching a show that's not
bendable so nice like getting together
with friends every week don't get to do
that much anymore and I'm really
enjoying it anyway
this episode was brought to you by
Squarespace if you want to make a
website and you want it to be a really
easy process Squarespace has some
beautiful award-winning designer
templates to choose from that makes the
process so so so simple it's got 24-hour
customer service no upgrades nothing to
install no patches ever and picking your
domain name is really easy construct
your free trial at squarespace.com and
if you use the offer code nerdwriter
you can get 10% off your first purchase
enjoy Game of Thrones guys well at last
and I'll see you next week
[Music]